the number one way in 2023 to get a
board game from 15 000 to a million is
posting four times a day on Tick Tock
the different creative that shows the
game three to four times on Instagram
four times that YouTube shorts three
times on LinkedIn Twitter threads meta
organic content on social networks at
the highest level that you can output is
going to give you what you want a few
years ago I spent three days with you in
Sydney yes had dinner with you you did a
live video with me fabulous uh at the
time we were in an event with about 30
people yes they were all asking you
questions about business and numbers and
I was a baby
our business had barely made nine
hundred thousand in three years
and I said to you what if it's not all
about business what if it's not all
about numbers what if you just get to
love people
and you gave to me
I'm gonna cry you gave me permission to
build a business loving people and there
are people in this room today
because I believed you
yes I have now made just under 10
million dollars since that time
and I [__] love you well thank you
this is just about gratitude thank you
for giving me permission to love people
thank you thank you Elizabeth
congratulations let's clap it up for
Elizabeth
look I really believe what just happened
with Elizabeth and I so so so much
not because I want to this is very
important for everyone to hear
I don't believe
being nice and doing things you like are
more likely to lead to money because I
want that to be the case
I actually want to be right
I need everybody to hear this
I'm not talking about this because it's
how I'd like it to be
I talk about it because it's how it is
and so I'd much rather be right than
almost anything
it's enjoyable
I mean it like I think people can
associate with that it's why I do all my
predictions when they're not really
predictions because they already
happened which is why I'm not wrong
often
I just observe quicker analyze faster
and create content around it quicker
than most
what just what Elizabeth just talked
about is super real
like I'm telling you I watch all of you
the world chasing the next Trend I've
literally watched in the last four years
hundreds of people that I see running
around the internet that have gone from
Cannabis experts to blockchain experts
to psychedelic experts
to AI experts
when they were never an expert of jack
[__]
stop chasing and stop start looking
inside and for her it was like hey I
like having this business but like me
it feels even better of what it's doing
with the people I'm working with
or for whom or who's buying my thing
and like if that's you then that's what
you need to focus on more than the p l
or maximizing your funnel
oh
hey Gary my name is corsi from
blockstars
um I've been following you since 2012.
thank you I really resonated with you
and said they thank you economy I loved
it and then you got it to um nfts yeah
Tech guy so I got a question
um we have a saying we say uh leave your
ego at the door yes come to the office
and you can take it home when you go
home yes
um but one of the things that I heard
recently said like
um I got [__] Eagle I don't really
swear much about this
um
sorry
um so okay
um so
um Can ego and being humble uh be at the
same time or are there two different
things no I think I think first of all
ego is slang for insecurity let's start
there
right and I think a lot of people mix up
confidence with ego
confidence is humility
and ego is insecurity so that's how I
see it I think you can be confident and
humble
but being insecure and humble is much
harder to contain in a container of a
human so that's how I say it awesome
thank you
I see it brother thank you
[Applause]
a bunch of us flew across from New
Zealand and they've come across from
Australia to see thank you thank you
some of our community we're up in
Indianapolis for Recon as well so let's
uh just want to express how grateful we
are that you're here today thank you my
friend I have a question and it's um
it's just around the web 3 space in my
place with v friends yes tactical so
please indulge me just I will yeah so I
saw you at the national last week yes
the sports bar convention in America
sports car trading yeah and uh I was
wondering about
um what the significance is of trading
cards their overall be friends strategy
because obviously be friends big web 3
play and I was just really interested to
see you going in so heavy on their IRL
uh training card space let me tell you a
story that I think will perfectly tell
you what I was doing there
there was a gentleman I spoke to on
Sunday of the card show that first
walked by the booth on Wednesday night
who had no idea who I was as a human
being and had never heard of be friends
on Thursday he stopped by again because
he saw all the commotion by the booth
and he bought a pack of cards to open
because he just wanted to learn Thursday
night he went to Google and started
doing homework Friday he came and bought
a bunch of the higher end cards because
he decided that maybe this could be like
a Pokemon
on Saturday evening he came up to me and
said hey I don't even know really what
an nft is
but is there somebody on your team that
can help me buy one of this character
because this is my favorite character
that I got in a pack of cards
that was what I was doing there
any defense party tonight or what sister
what's up brother we gotta be friends
party tonight yes I'm gonna stop by real
quick I think look nobody's gonna buy a
Spider-Man comic book number one unless
there's Spider-Man cartoons and
Spider-Man movies nobody's gonna do
anything from a collectible standpoint
unless they care about the characters I
need to create the character demand in
the physical and the digital world and I
think that's my major strategy thank you
bro you got it brother
hi Gary hi nice to be here my name is
Rebecca Rebecca I've got a really
successful coaching business I'm a oh
there we go I'm a business coach okay I
have grown to multiple seven figures in
a couple of years and at the moment I
have these high quality problem that
every person that steps into my world I
make them feel like they're the only
person in my world and I have these
steep close connection with my clients
and I have this fear of really scaling
and taking you to the next level because
my only concern right now is I don't
want to lose that Personal Touch the
fields with my clients yes how would you
suggest that I do that still remaining
in Integrity whilst allowing my business
to scale
by charging more money
can do
right like if you have a lot of passion
for being that Hands-On but you also
have a passion for it to make more
Revenue the answer to the question is
more money they have to pay more yeah
right and that's okay that's a business
model but that even if you hit the
highest level of what a business coach
can make
it will still tap out because you're one
human correct
if you want to keep growing your
business you'll have to give that up
you'll have to do other things that's a
decision you have to make yeah you know
and so there's two ways one you change
or adapt or add to your philosophical
emotional religious point of view on
your high touch strategy or you charge
more or you do both
but you're fully in control of that
amazing thank you so much you're welcome
thank you of course
my name is
um hi Gary my name is Nika um Brisbane a
couple of years ago and thank you so
much for coming back again of course um
so you're a person who's very self-aware
and Trust in the process
um what are some key indicators you've
noticed in your own experience that have
come up when you're on the brink of a
breakthrough basically saying to not
give up and to keep going through
the definition of a breakthrough is you
don't know okay
right yeah yeah which is why I keep
going back to what I want to tell
everybody which is how about you make it
about enjoying it versus the need for
the Breakthrough right
I appreciate the six people that
understood what I was [__] saying
which is going to make me say it again
that more people didn't go all the way
there with me I'm going to say it again
the concept of a break breakthrough is a
really great question because a lot of
people here are grinding and they're
asking themselves hey I wanted to have
this business or this thing
even relationships I wanted this
and now it's been a while and it's not
there is it ever going to happen should
I jump off
should I change this is man and woman's
biggest question a lot of times
and the answer is you're not going to
know
you're just not sure you can see gradual
but like you know this when you're
grading your own homework
it's not the truth
like most people think their kid is good
looking
you know but in reality like not
everyone is good looking
but we all as parents think our kids are
the cutest we're grading our own
homework we're not letting the Merit of
the world grade
same here
I'm thinking of this from a different
perspective I'm asking you why do you
need the Breakthrough
yeah I think it's the the people
pleasing and it's not being able to say
no to other people and wanting to
um
yeah just to prove it to yourself and to
other people and you don't want to do
that no there is no proving to oneself
yeah that's disguise to I want to prove
it to someone else yeah
proving to oneself
you never think about proving
you're just living
you don't even talk in words of proof
you're trying to prove to someone else
thank you mommy daddy
like those things and that's what we're
all doing
I don't want you to prove to any if you
were driven this is why Star Wars
figured it out
I mean it there's either the good side
like the you know the Jedis and the dark
side they're just so close it's an inch
they're being fueled by different things
but they both get there but in the end
the light love wins
you can't be driven
by proving it to the parent or another
person that [__] you up
you have to find a way to do it for
yourself then you're not looking for the
Breakthrough you're just living happily
yeah thank you so much
what's happening Gary how are you life
is good my man what's your name my name
is Mana nice to meet you brother
um this is pretty surreal for me because
in 2017 you know I was lost no Direction
found myself having to live back home my
parents embarrassed about that because I
was a grown ass man you know doing that
and uh I knew I had to change my mind
and needed some a good kick in the ass
and so I typed in Inspiration a
motivation or something like that on
Instagram or YouTube and came across you
and I started listening and then slowly
started changing my mind and then fast
forward six years I'm living thousands
thousands of miles away here in
Australia and have my own business so
um
I think I speak you know not only for
myself but everyone else in this room
when I say thank you for inspiring and
motivating and telling us the things we
need to hear and not always what we want
to hear so
um
my question is will you go live with me
so we can make this come around full
circle right now yeah right now sure
so you set up and get your [__] together
there you're good you can go right there
I'll just do this because I love
efficiency go ahead you tell me when
yours is really ready and enough people
run there you go Gary my name is Stuart
you can call me coxy coxy I'm ready but
uh
I'm setting up a health Media company
and it's all about healthy communication
yes and I see what you're doing here is
very much healthy Communication in
regards to respect for people and
whatnot thank you sir now I'm a man of
science and a man of you know clinical
experience yes sir
and we're in this period whereby there's
a lot of
discussion with Tick Tock and short form
flickable screen stuff yes and children
that have been parented by a constant or
a lazy parenting you could say okay or
what the pediatricians say yes
it's creating a lot of anxiety and a lot
of add behaviors in children who are
needing a lot of therapy and getting
thrown a lot of drugs okay do you see
where we're getting to a point where
potentially that's going to be a
intervention whereby tick tocks like
okay hang on a second people are just
going to start dropping this thing if
there's a bunch of evidence leaning in
this direction
and will there be
you know is there going to be a shift
away from that or will Tick-Tock change
or will it move back towards other
deliverable media
um I think there's a lot to that so a
couple things one
ah
the conversation we had earlier about
accountability really matters I'll give
you an example when I was 14 the
conversation wasn't Tick Tock Because
the Internet hadn't happened and phones
hadn't happened the conversation was
supermodels that were 90 pounds that led
to every girl in my high school being in
the bathroom during school throwing up
because they thought 90 pounds was the
gold standard and the demon of the day
was MTV and magazines
uh in America in the 1930s this question
was asked it was around alcohol
right we needed to ban it we banned
alcohol in America right the I think
this question is going to evolve into
non-lazy parenting accountability and
the way everything works in life which
is balance
there's people that talk about sugar
this way there's people that talk about
speed limits this way I think that
there's a lot of things we can talk
about and I think that by the time we
get around to properly regulating or
understanding this the attention of the
consumer is going to go somewhere else I
believe you and I will be sitting here
in 20 years talking about the dangers of
the metaverse because we don't leave our
home because we're in VR and we'll look
back to the days of tick tock and think
of it as mundane the way that everyone
told me that playing video games all day
was [__] up everyone and that's the
reason everyone had add 20 years ago was
because we played video games all day so
I think there is balance in everything
and I believe in government playing a
role in regulating but I really believe
in humans thinking about the
accountability of it and so no I don't
think tick tock's going to change
because tick tock's empty tick tock's a
super empty vessel brother their
business is very simple we are going to
build an algorithm that only gives you
more of what you've shown us you want
period
and so I think that that's where the
world's going to go that we're going to
continue to get smarter about
accountability just like we did in
America with alcohol Banning alcohol
didn't fix the problem educating people
of how to find balance with alcohol has
made the problem better not demonizing
people that have alcoholism and
realizing it's a disease has made the
issue better
not talking about domestic violence as
something that was whispered behind the
scenes but putting it to the Forefront
has made things better so I think that's
what's going to end up happening with it
matter we'll say that having a
conversation eye to eye and in person
you're a great example it's a thousand
eggs compared to a screen
[Applause]
bro you know it takes a second for
everyone to come keep it live I'll be
there in two seconds go ahead hey Gary
how are you today good mate awesome
that's fantastic sort of seem a little
bit nervous I'm a little bit new to this
whole entrepreneurial sort of thing but
you're not new to speaking thank you
thank you very much uh my name is Jake
by the way I'm 20 years old I live in
Brisbane yes sir um I I'm going to be
honest I did remember what I was going
to say but it's fine out of my head
all right let's clap it up for Jake
I think first of all I really appreciate
how attentive you are to each individual
that's coming up to the microphone and
also just everyone as a whole
um it makes me feel really I feel I feel
much more comfortable now that I'm
looking at you I know I felt very
nervous coming up here no worries um
because I'm very new to business I'm
finding it a little bit difficult to
discuss with my parents about what I'm
doing and getting them on their whole
you know supportive parenting wagon I
just want to know I don't know I'd
assume to be people here that might have
similar experience a very common thing
yeah I was just wondering well why do
you want them to be supportive that's
actually a really good question that's
actually that's actually a really good
question I feel as if it's a little bit
of a moral obligation for me coming back
from a European background it's very
family-oriented and as by the sounds of
it you're very close with your parents
yeah I'm just wondering do you have any
advice around that and maybe what would
be the best way to get them on board
with what I'm doing there is no
convincing in life
oh I want everybody to hear this this is
the pro this is a huge problem right now
the answer to the question is go and
execute and be successful and watch how
your parents change their tune okay yeah
there's that thank you but I'm gonna use
your question to talk about something
else there is no convincing in life you
this is why politics makes me laugh as
if your view on the world
is the Right View
everyone's spending all their time
trying to convince everyone else to see
the world exactly the way they see it
instead of convincing brother why not
take that energy and make it about
conviction so not convincing
conviction with yourself on this journey
and be empathetic to why your parents
see it this way they might have been
academic they might have immigrated here
and they didn't do all this hard work
for you to take a high risk feeling
parents navigate through fear
they're scared you're gonna fail
okay yeah yeah the parents also use
their children as a proxy to their own
self-esteem too often well okay they're
not only scared that you're gonna fail
for you because they love you they're
scared that you're gonna fail because
they're worried about what other people
are going to think about you okay right
have compassion for that but I'm a news
alert you're not going to convince them
so don't spend any minutes on that
because you need those minutes to go and
execute your [__] awesome Jake thank you
thank you so much and I just wanted to
say one last thing for you guys I um I
have 100 faith in myself that I'll be
working with you in a few years and I
hope everyone else here has that Vision
as well because you're an amazing voice
to this generation and I appreciate you
and can I come up and Shake Your Hand by
the way I can't really really see what
you started
thank you you ready now
[Laughter]
I know how to turn it around
all right we're here [__] on live
here he is he asked here's [__]
Brisbane
something these three people on here
three is better than zero let me finish
my point these print people on here
always always understand this moment
those three people are the single most
important three people
notice how when I was trying to say
something when I said three the laugh
game because we get it I get it but the
reason I stand here today with more than
three people is because of my original
three people
[Applause]
bye everyone
hi Gary how are you my name is
Michelangelo Michelangelo thank you for
coming
um you're welcome I've been following
you for a little while and and the
Enigma that you are there's a question I
want to I would only ask a person in
person yes subscribe to you sometimes to
people as like he's like the Rick Rubin
entrepreneurs you know and uh I've seen
a transformation of you like tripling
down on authenticity yeah I have a
personal question that you don't have to
answer or you can
um just to kind of get that Clarity of
character that does amaze a lot of
people you know what what's something
in your life that someone has done or
you've observed that that's that's been
real authentic kindness that you will
never forget oh that's a great fun
question Michael and
[Applause]
you know it's a really good question so
I would say
by a distant margin the way my mom has
lived her life is very clear when I hear
this question
I've just watched her
spend her entire life
giving energy to everyone without asking
any in return
you know and so it's funny when you ask
the question it's a good question and I
really tried to go into my mind on can I
think of anything that is more one-off
than what I just answered
right I was thinking like that's good
that's the answer that came right away
but I think I've established that and
I'm sitting here quickly as you're
asking it is there something else I can
say that might bring value as well
but then as I process it it's just so
obvious to me that there's not even a
distant second I'll tell you where it
shows up now that I could build on what
I just said by observing my mom lived
that life
and by having a similar DNA and then
being inspired and parented to do the
same
what has happened is something
interesting which is I see it very
clearly in young children
outside
the purest form of kindness I see
is when kids normally under the age of
eight
stop what they're doing when they're
playing
when one of them gets hurt when I watch
eight kids at a playground play and
somebody gets hurt almost always all
seven or six other kids continue to play
but one comes over and Comforts that
child that deeply empathetic under
eight-year-old
is the one I thought of when you asked
me the question
you know what do you know do you
understand what I'm saying because what
that represents for me is they haven't
even lived life enough to know about
anything they're just doing it because
they're doing it there is no reason
they're doing it it's in them and this
is why I'm passionate about empathy and
kindness and compassion and sympathy
because it's good
it's really good and if you really watch
the internet this is why I want more of
you to go out in the world and observe
and I think the edges are interesting
under eight over 80.
there's a lot of [__] answers there
don't do it with people in your family
because that's too contextual it's too
convoluted it's got baggage
start like the next time you go to the
airport watch
look for 80 year olds and look for
eight-year-olds and watch you'll get
really interesting answers
my brother you got ready yes love you
man I love you back brother
um a couple of things happening in my
life we're a Mexican family uh
immigrated to New Zealand 20 years ago
well I reflect a lot with your family
and what happened with your parents yes
um two things happened uh five years ago
I started following you and I broke the
relationship with my daughter
you started following me and what
happened so
it's emotional what did you say I didn't
hear you so
um
your daughter got a tattoo on the arm
and I thought the life was over you know
for me life was over when she got a
tattoo yeah because I thought because
you're an old school [__] dude yeah
but because of that I thought what is my
family is going to think about it of
course and I don't never thought about
what actually my child think about
itself you know that's right and then I
was lying in bed and I watched your
video to say what the [__] we think
about it you know what about their kids
what they think about themselves well
worry about what actually what our
parents are everything else back in
Mexico miles away what I'm worried about
it that's right and that moment like
what I'm doing like I'm ready to break
the relationship with my own daughter
then I because the tattoo she got yeah
because back home your mom your uncle
your dad who yeah yeah with all them the
all of them but the whole [__] family
in Mexico yeah who's gonna [__] on you
yeah because your daughter got a small
tattoo on her wrist yes I understand go
ahead
anyway in that moment my life completely
changed I said what the [__] I'm doing
you know like
I absolutely love my daughter that's
right yeah five years ago I started my
own business yes the first people I
employ my family and my friends yes in
Mexico we have a say nerd employee
family and friends yes and then suddenly
I still got ready to say only hire your
family and friends yes brother you know
what I just realized I'm about to get
into a huge [__] fight with Mexico
so thank you very much I'm very hungry
we're at 10 million dollar company we
are 35 employees three companies we got
our own media
agency yeah I work for the three
companies for everything else what a
true inspiration thank you very much for
being who you are thank you we love you
I have a big idea before I have a big
idea
I think you need to go home grab your
daughter and go to the tattoo parlor and
you should get a tattoo
that's awesome
I love that you got him to swear and he
used to be worried about a tattoo that's
right
that's really cool hi Gary my name is
Zoe hey so I just want to film this
because I'll figure everything you've
got give it to one of those handsome
guys there so they can hold it for you
if that's okay yeah of course you don't
have to film him just so I can hear it
later
um hi nice to meet you pleasure delay
Bruce Vegas thank you um so I recently
launched my business in economy and wipe
company because I needed these products
for my son when he had a baby they
weren't available yes so I'm brand new
just launched it's all me and I wrote
this down because it's like that guy
over there how do they get here you
don't want to forget good for you good
so my question is when you've just
launched and it's more or less just you
yes
um where do you focus your time if you
were me what would you be focusing your
time on I know there's social media
there's marketing I've got to pack
orders emails because phone calls I have
a son yes a life of school things where
do you focus your time on the business
and your money and two things okay
notice how I said eat in 80 before yes I
hate the middle
the middle is a commodity The Edge is
where it's interesting so the answer to
your question is the following I would
focus on my things when it's just you on
the things I've done in the same
scenario and the things that I've
observed from many that works a the [__]
that's most on fire
right whatever is [__] most on fire
it's like being in a boat if there's a
hole over here you got to put your
finger there right the things that are
most on fire and then B the things you
like the most out of all the things
you're doing
things
I like the most whatever those things
are things are making the product
whatever it is
to have the energy to fix the [__]
that's most on fire that will get you to
the next phase where you can start
bringing people in and afford to do the
things you don't want to do
does that make sense yeah that's good
the key though right now so that's a
good framework for you to think about
but the key that you have to really lean
into right now is realize that you have
to lean into patience it's impossible
for it to happen overnight I'm very
patient good and what you need to do is
just realize it's just a process and
find the things that you enjoy about it
and then more importantly I think you
have a really really strong product
Market fit my favorite business in the
world always is when somebody starts
something to scratch their own itch or
an itch they had and so I think you've
got to stay with that conviction because
you're going to help a lot of people
thanks Gary you're welcome Zoe
hey Gary what's up brother
um my name is Ananda
um and I run a real estate digital
marketing agency here in Brisbane but
it's a privilege to be even able to
stand here and ask you this question man
thank you I'm 23 years old I've been
listening to you since I was probably I
don't know [__] 14 or something
talking to an uncle
but fair enough bro go ahead
um so as a young guy who's pretty new
into business uh
I've I've we've hit like the six figure
run rate pretty quickly in my journey
but what I've figured out was that was
holding me back a lot was the fact that
there's a thing going around there's a
standard version of a product in an
industry yes and there are tons of
people in my own network all around the
world that are kind of doing pretty much
the same thing makes sense
but I'm not able to just do the same
thing as everyone else because I'm not I
don't just want to make money I just
wanna I wanna make a product that is
truly exceptional that's great so how
would I approach that when everyone
seems to be doing just pretty much the
same thing
by doing what you just said
but how do you know you know what is a
next step on top of all these other like
huge companies out there that are
already doing very similar things well
if you have the ambition and the
audacity to make a truly exceptional
product you need to put in the work to
figure it out that question
is that something you did at vaynermedia
um yes I decided to not do what you're
doing right now which was give any
attention to anybody else doing anything
and I focused 100 of my attention on my
people and on honing my craft at being
the best social media marketing company
in the world even though everybody else
who was multi-billion dollar companies
told me it could never work
everybody else is a waste of time
thank you
hi Gary hi I'm so excited to talk to you
I'm Jess Jess
um I have a I'm I'm in a software
development company SAS SAS platforms
Marketplace platforms yep really awesome
we work with um small to medium
businesses good only issue is small to
medium businesses don't pay consistently
they don't pay at all
it's like yeah they sometimes yes so we
move into corporate okay corporate's
great except I'm not really a fit for
corporate my personality yeah yes I'm
Jess yeah I do stand-up comedian I'm a
stand-up comedian I try to be I'm
actually quite bad at it fair enough I
but you like it I do I love it go ahead
put that on social media and I share
that to create a following yes I have a
day where i'm inspired by something I
put that on social media to create my
phone so why is that not corporate well
incorporate some of it I think my
business partner cringes at it sounds
like your business partner is the
problem not corporate easy kids
[Applause]
oh [__]
um hey he's actually pretty good he
actually is pretty good he's here right
he is yeah
he'd be cringing right now yes
um what I what I'm saying is with all
your experience and I think I just need
the permission from you does it actually
wreck your brand if you're building you
know we're building platforms for big
corporates uh actually I have a business
yes that does three 400 million dollars
in Revenue around the globe
to Fortune 500 companies and I post the
most outlandish
I post me going to garage sales I curse
every third word on LinkedIn I dress
like a [__] teenage boy
what the [__] do you think the answer is
sorry one more question does it exclude
people yes
okay
but you want to hear something really
digest it too do you want to hear
something funny sure it also includes
people
does it exclude people 100 percent
but do I believe that you will get
customers because you are silly or
ridiculous and they're like [__] it I'd
rather go with her because I'm silly and
ridiculous too and I get to write the
check over here in corporate I do
and it sounds like you and your partner
are actually a good [__] combo
because if you're silly and here's he or
she he isn't well now you've given
companies both options
you're welcome thank you
[Applause]
hey Gary my name is Joe Joe thank you so
much for coming down and uh taking the
37 hours whatever flight it is to get
here 26 26 hours well done thank you
I've been blessed enough to have been
running my own training business now for
the last 17 years focusing on emotional
Fitness and uh it's the core mission of
emotional Fitness in our world is to
transform people's relationship with
uncertainty yes and it's done wonders to
massively reduce anxiety and depression
people have been working and also it's
actually helped so many fall back in
love with themselves makes sense yeah
and
um I I'm just I have no idea how to
transform this business into a movement
into scaling it into a movement by
putting out content on the internet
right
you do know I've been doing that I've
been doing that more right
how much don't lie cause I'll look it up
yeah
I've got I've got a private group called
emotional Fitness Hub that's not doing
so that's no good no okay you're talking
to seven people right the world has a
billion sure
sure so so we're talking daily
um
multiple dailies as many as many as I
can I would if you could post 39 times a
day 39 different messages on nine
different platforms I'll take it right
okay but I'll definitely take one from
you because right now you're just
talking to a group of a small group of
people and you're trying to change the
world and that's not going to work right
okay changing the world looks like you
giving the information to the world for
free and expecting nothing in return yes
[Applause]
we'll keep going a little bit
I'll do as much as I can go ahead hi hey
Gary nice to meet you nice to meet you
my name's Tasha Burke hi Tasha
um I'm a creative good
um it's yeah it can be good it's great
yeah it is great but it's also a
struggle sometimes but everything's a
struggle sometimes correct thank you
um so
so I've got millions of ideas like
creative people do but I've had an idea
of some nfts for a while okay so I just
wanted to see what you thought about
where the nft space is at the moment do
you think it's really bad yeah
yep
But but so was internet after the
Internet stock crash
in 2000
all the people that are making fun of
nfts now to the friends that were in
10fts were the same people in 2020
making fun of the internet excuse me
2000 making fun of the internet Because
the Internet stocks crashed yeah
nfts and the blockchain are massively
profound Technologies it was greed
that made a crash but the technology
still exists and if you were to execute
a meaningfully strong nft project and
knew how to build demand for it and
brought value you would succeed okay 99
of people fail in real estate 99 of
people fail in their business 99 of
sports cards and sneakers and art aren't
worth anything you need to focus on
being the one percent not worrying about
what's happening with nfts yeah
thank you you're welcome
[Applause]
especially because you're a creative and
the best thing to be when you're a
creative is actually making what you
want to make
you don't need it to be commercially
viable you need to get some of your
million ideas out into the world that's
what being creative is
sorry
hi my name is Darian how are you good
thank you so much for having me here I
actually won tickets and um it's just
such an honest video so thank you
um I'm 26 years old I run a tutoring and
mentoring business
um I started a few years ago and we've
been doubling in Revenue every year
congrats thank you I'm 43 staff
um and I grew up in foster care yes
after my really rough upbringing and my
connection to the kids that I work with
I'm desperate to be a role model on a
much larger scale than what I'm working
on now makes sense and I've done three
talks yes my first talk was a tedx talk
okay which was incredibly nerve-wracking
thank you
and I really want to know how to go up
from here because it feels like I've
started off strong and very quickly
stagnated
and I just don't know where to go next
oh there's a lot to this so first of all
I2 at 26
because of a very different upbringing
had incredible passion to make an impact
and I didn't even speak until I was 33
to almost no one very far away from a
tedx talk yeah
what I think you're doing is putting
yourself into a position to mentally
fail
because you're not being patient
right yeah yeah just because your next
talk might be smaller not as fancy as
tedx it doesn't mean that you're not
impacting
your ability to impact is similar to Joe
like you should be making content every
day about this yeah and you shouldn't be
putting the magnitude of the speech on a
pedestal you should be putting doing the
work for people on a pedestal yeah and
that's ultimately where the heart's
coming from right I want to impact but I
just want to impact more yes I know that
even you even the way you story told
right you talked about 43 employees
that's impressive people reacted you
talked about tedx
it makes so much sense to me that you
want to put things into context to speak
to it but if you're talking about
helping
you can't be doing any of the helping
for vanity or insecurity you have to be
doing it for helping yep so just focus
on the helping not impressing us for
sure
thank you you're welcome
all right oh my God I feel sick hi Gary
I'm Mel Mel
um I like your hat thanks it's really
furry
um I kind of try to keep this really
short you can fix the mic if you want
okay hi
um so I own a hair extension business
and I've been you are you know what a
hair extension company a hair extension
we've done a lot of education and uh we
are quite like we've been in business
for quite a long time we're doing quite
well however we run courses at the
moment and we teach like other salons
how to do hair I'm aware of the concert
and okay but there's quite a lot of
people in my space that I've always
added to which is why I'm aware of the
confidence but they so they do the same
thing but they're also allowing people
that have no qualification to learn this
as well yeah now I have there's two
sides of me there's one side of me
that's like no you have to be qualified
you've always had to be I had to do what
everyone else does do it it's not fair
you don't know enough and then there's
the other side of me that's going wake
the [__] up melts 2023 things have
changed that piece of paper doesn't mean
anything from the government
is going to
cause some hurricanes in the industry
because I know a lot of people in my
space have that same mindset as Mel
number one is that okay what does that
have to do with male number three that's
sitting in front of me I think because
for a long time now on my with my
audience I do have a lot of loyal
clients I have built that clientele
because we felt the same about not
having people that aren't qualified
doing the extensions okay and now I
think that when my mindset changes I I
guess I'm scared because the people that
love me because we think the same about
that are then going to be like you've
always preached that you need to be
qualified to do it why would you talk
about it at all
they'll see what I'm doing like if I'm
allowing people that aren't cool I see
you're talking about the concept of
you're going to start taking on people
who are not glorified well there's no
licensing in my industry but it doesn't
make sense that I should license it if
the government doesn't I understand so I
don't know what to do well it sounds
like you're gonna have you know it
sounds like you're trading on an
ideology that the market doesn't give a
[__] about and that your small Market
that you have right now even though it's
doing well yeah gives the [__] about it
but when the majority of the market
doesn't it sounds like you're about to
give yourself an opportunity to have a
bigger Market I definitely will and it
will be harder because it they need to
learn more and I can give them that I'm
actually a great teacher I believe in me
and my product you have to basically
make a decision if you want to hold on
to this ideology yeah just fine and have
less upside financially yeah or if
you're finally ready to let go of that
ideology and give your business more
growth and I am I just needed to hear it
you got it
laughs
hi Gary how are you Demers I'm wonderful
thank you good being here with us of
course I'm raising capital for my
startup something which I've never done
before okay I don't have any track
record uh in business or in career yes
and so if this was you how would you
turn that lack of experience into a
positive and conversations with
investors or put another way what would
you emphasize instead to instill
confidence with investors
um you're not going to be able to make
it a positive for most people
because you basically said I've I've no
experience and I've never done anything
professionally give me money
what I would do in that scenario is ask
as many people as possible for money and
hope I got lucky
that's like literally how it works
brother that's pretty much where I'm at
yeah how many and do you feel stuck no
I've just said I'm just starting that so
I was waking up to do it yeah got my
pitch deck I think yeah I think the
other thing you can do is make content
about what you're thinking about doing
which will lead to potential demand but
here with no experience and no track
record
you're gonna have to have someone buy
into you yeah so you just got to tell
them the truth okay and it's gonna
probably be one out of 100 people yep
and that's great
because that's better than nobody
thank you another quick question I was
at the very first V con so I live here
now and I traveled there I tried to give
you a custom nft and how we didn't quite
square that up could I even if it's a
private wallet yes I know how you feel
about that I would love to do that
I'll send you what wallet that's what I
did
a lot
try again
thank you
and you know what's funny about that
little fun exchange you're gonna need to
have that to do what you're about to do
you might actually get money from a
person who pitch a second time
go ahead bud
hi Gary my name is Craig from Australia
respect respect to you respect to your
parents thank you brother
um you're always about adding value and
bringing value to people yes that's the
reason I'd like to stand up here today
um basically started as an actor for
eight years sucked at it really bad had
the humility to realize that I didn't
have the talent wasn't going to make it
I guess smashed my head against the wall
yes started a business which I wanted to
do
it fell on its ass yep jumped into the
next one
did the same thing I've just come out of
that see we're over three so far
so far yeah so so far so far
the thing I regret the absolute most
about that is absolutely [__] nothing
amazing yeah
wouldn't wouldn't change a thing about
it have had the humility to go back
start working start again back in the
bat cave and love getting ready for the
next one love
that's it that's it
when I tell you
when I say that's it I actually say that
in the best way possible that you're
you're absolutely right for coming up
here and saying that because that [__]
fires me up to no end me too because
that's what I'm hoping for people to
understand
because if you have no regrets and you
sit up here and deliver what you just
delivered the way you did yep and you're
enjoying the concept of one of these
things is going to hit and you don't
have regret do you know me brother do
you know how many people wanted to be
actors and didn't try yeah it's [__]
huge that you did that for eight years
yeah like just not like when you're
sitting on that rocking chair at 91 and
not having to be like I wish I did
because that's the thing you'll learn if
you hang out with 80 and 90 year olds
they don't talk about anything and I
mean anything if they're a stranger to
you anything besides two things
happy or sad about how much time they
spent with their family in their life
meaning thrilled they did a ton of it
and they feel content or sad and wish
they spent more
and then number two the [__] they didn't
do
the [__] they didn't do I'm pumped for
you bro that you scratched that itch for
you I appreciate it and look you know
it's all about like you say not having
regrets I've heard you say that many
times it's a big one connected I will
never look back and go you know I wonder
what would have happened because I now I
know what happened I learned so much and
it's changed me so much for the better
I've taken all three of those things
with me brother Ron when I tell you I
can't wait to see you go one for seven
can't wait
thank you thank you
so hi Gary my name is Emma Emma so how
could you build confidence and
credibility from scratch as a public
speaker in Australia when you come from
a different culture and speaks a
different language by speaking at places
that are quite small for free and doing
it until
you stop
yeah like you know you can't convince
people
to like or dislike your accent you can't
you just have to go home right now go to
Google type in conferences speaking
Australia find somebody find conferences
email them say this is me
I would like to speak preferably you've
made some content on the internet so
they can look at it most will say no
one will say yes you'll go up and do it
it will either go well or not well
you'll get off stage and decide if you
want to do it again and that's it
you're not going to build confidence
or get people to like your accent by
sitting at home thinking about it
you just have to do
can I take your hands really quickly
what's up brother hey Gary my name is
Brolin uh how about a hug instead hey
[Applause]
Sam
don't think about
they like your accent good if they don't
like your accent good yeah
[Music]
hi my name is Roland and uh
I've come to see you in Brisbane most
times hopefully all of them and your
values of
encourage a lot of positive fulfillment
in my life so thank you for that thank
you and uh I also want to say Ethan I
haven't heard of you before I've been to
a lot of these shows I didn't know what
we're going to get with mindset matters
I brought a backpack with a laptop I
thought I was going to sit there all day
waiting for Gary to come on
thank you for not putting on a day with
full of [__] people trying to sell us
things
[Applause]
thank you wish you all the success thank
you my question is I um started a
business it's an app and we're kicking a
few goals in Australia is it called
cruncher it is I got a government grant
to take it to the US very nice and um
I've studied the fundamentals of
marketing every which way possible
I've got a hundred thousand dollars to
spend in two years yes and I don't know
where to start what would you like to
happen
I don't want to be one of these
foolished startups where we get photos
with this all in t-shirts and have PR
campaigns I want us to earn The
credibility from people loving the
product and what we do for them good so
you get the money and it's a big place
there's businesses that say we could do
this we can do that we should we should
do but you would I assume you want
people to download the app
I want people to understand what we do
without it coming across as being the
standard marketing
campaign I want to know what I've found
is that you know we've worked with
Google we've worked with a whole heap of
different marketing businesses in
Australia yep and everyone's got their
own ideas of being a genius but what's
worked best for us is the genuine Story
the door knocking the face-to-face
people telling other people and so do
that all the money in the world
isn't going to solve that issue I'm just
wondering how to what what to start with
knocking on the doors and doing hand to
hand
it sounds like the money's confusing you
because you're on two sides of the
equation of what you know has worked and
what you like to do
versus what the money gives you in
options
it sounds like you should take the money
and hire another person that shares your
values so you can scale the hand-to-hand
combat
and
what is that hand-to-hand combat look
like in the states how do you knock on
doors with money
on Doors
right like what
Australia
we're still trying
we're still trying but you want to do
more feel like that's working for you
well I know what's going to work and I
know what everybody else says works it's
a matter of you know tag and release tag
and release and see what comes back and
we're still in that process
so yeah I mean I think it's similar to a
theme of a lot of questions here is it
sounds like you have an ideology
versus knowing a practicality
let me ask you a different question
what do you think is going to work you
said to me you know what's going to work
tell me what's going to work great
social media campaign okay and you don't
want to do that I do but I'm not sure
how to start it because there's so many
sharks in the water you know so I think
I mean there's a lot of different ways
to go about that obviously people post
to him there's a million people that are
this guy or this guy I think you should
go learn it for yourself okay cool it
sounds what will work for you is not
what they're saying about this guy or
this guy it sounds in the way that
you're asking the questions and how
you're thinking about it is you should
go not worry about the money you should
go allocate the hundreds of hours to get
good at it so you can do it yourself
excellent thank you you're welcome I
also just want to say um something that
may benefit other people in the room
just quickly and you can come back to it
after I don't want to hug the mic but um
I've got two small kids and I've got a
story similar to what we talked about
earlier
um where parents didn't have much time
you know I was on the railroad tracks
too loved it and um now I've got two
small kids and we spend so much time we
take them to gymnastics swimming they're
both under three yes
is there a danger in that now
of course bring up a soft generation of
course
the answer to everything is always
balance right you shouldn't not spend
time with your kids
but you shouldn't be so up in their
business and know everything about them
and fight their fights awesome I got it
thank you
pleasure me uh my name is England and I
just want to say thank you
thank you brother yeah
yeah I appreciate that
that was way too quick I wasn't prepared
for that
all right he understood the assignment
yeah so
and all the love that's been uh shared
your way today uh I wanna you know just
add my voice to that like the amount of
gratitude uh and you know uh amazing
empathy and everything that you're
putting out into the world it's amazing
to have your voice you know out there
it's the world it's awesome man so thank
you yeah just wanted to thank you on
behalf of everyone and thank the whole
world really I guess thank you
so my name is Kyle I run a digital
marketing agency called social gigs um
three years ago I started working with
an amazing company called Sharing
kindness which uh the founder of Tess
she started it to teach her kids her two
young daughters resilience and kindness
and gratitude love the brand like I've
gone all in on this brand it's amazing
good um so last year we launched a game
on Kickstarter uh it sold out got a
whole bunch of pre-sales and uh we're
we're now just trying to get it out
there uh you know we sold about 15 000
units over the last year which is an
awesome thing to see yes um what we're
trying to do is get it into like a
million homes you know really trying to
get it out there to as many people as we
can because that's all based on positive
psychology kids empathy and kindness and
I'm in you know so we're trying to get
this out there and you're like the the
world's you know biggest voice on this
oh no I'm not please don't speak on my
behalf
I mean I'm into understanding what he
was saying I'm not going to co-sign the
game yeah no I wasn't looking for a
coach but I guess what I was looking for
is basically if we were to channel
garyvee you know one of the best
marketers in the world how would you
recommend in 2023 to build up like
social media Community behind it get
people really involved so that you're
getting that kind of you know are you
want to say produce content aren't you
yeah yeah I mean you know what the funny
part is of like why my world is what I
talk about in business is similar to the
way people talk in health and fitness
everyone's walking around saying how do
I get into better shape or feel better
let me save you time you eat better
you get your protein ratios up you don't
eat as much sugar and carbs and all that
dog [__] you eat cleaner you go to the
gym
you work on building up your strength
everyone the the formula is super simple
there's nobody here that doesn't
understand how to get into better
physical shape
doing it is hard
the number one way in 2023 to get a
board game from 15 000 to a million is
posting four times a day on Tick Tock
with different creative that shows the
game three to four times on Instagram
four times that YouTube shorts three
times on LinkedIn Twitter threads meta
organic content on social networks at
the highest level that you can output is
going to give you what you want nice
thanks man you got it
hey there what's up Gary my name is okay
I'm Muhammad I'm here with my friend
ansu um we're both in the real estate
industry in e-commerce we're both 16 so
what advice would you give us to set
ourselves from other entrepreneurs
that you don't need to set yourself up
in a different way than other
entrepreneurs the fact that you're both
16 yeah
a lot of people worry about notice the
themes if you've been listening you
don't need to worry about other
entrepreneurs
you don't need to worry about it
you need to keep honing your skills
there's only so much [__] you could be
doing in real estate when you're 16.
right yeah like you're just early
like you just need to keep practicing
don't worry about setting apart from
everyone else just worry about you being
good at it
does that make sense yeah how's it going
pretty good what's going well
um I'm good on the phone and door
knocking I'm getting leads yes
um yeah so you're not scared of getting
those no that's a very good [__]
start thank you
let me tell you my favorite piece of
advice to a 16 year old entrepreneur
who's hungry
how you make your money
is more important than how much you make
keep that in mind okay guys come get a
picture with you please yes sir
because that team got started this [__]
I gotta go cool hey hi Gary you're
awesome thank you what's your name my
name is Carolyn Zanetti Carolyn how are
you I'm fabulous I also want to say
thank you to this guy I love your story
and I'm excited to scale with ads so you
rock thank you for holding the vision
and bringing this Legend and asking for
what you want and creating it thank you
and
um
I actually just came up here for the
opportunity and have thought of the best
question and
uh I am all about nervous system
regulation emotional regulation with
somatics embodiment tools and I know
your Mr mindset and I believe in both
top down bottom up yep and I thought a
powerful question would be I would love
to
speak to your team and give them some
nervous system regulation tools I'm a
genius at it and I've got loads of value
to share to help them be more calm alive
and move from procrastination Perfection
but by feeling safe in their body to
receive their desires and have that
energy so could I is that was that a
question yes it seemed more like a pitch
yes I thought but I thought that might
be smart like oh sharing tools that I
could help you and yourself you are more
than welcome to email me that
dot com
yeah put all your Spiel in there and I'm
happy to look at it okay great and I
thought I would do an exchange for a
short 20 Minute Podcast right now you're
getting obnoxious okay okay and can I
have a hug you can have the hug
my man
what's up G
um I'm Damian from New Zealand no thank
you you're welcome have a great day yes
what's up I'm Damon from New Zealand I
got that hug at Beacon it was great hug
I love your hat a nice hat did you bring
your pins I don't have any pins on me
um so I experienced a vegan at the start
of econ you talked around how everyone
was going to be there who came you know
it's a family that Journey that you'd
see would go on from strangers to
acquaintances to friends or family yeah
and that was for me the epitome of econ
like it was it was what it was it was
what it was everyone I was talking to
everyone loved that
um and so I'm I run a small agency
working with Shopify uh and I was
wondering with all the wins that you've
had through V friends and building vpns
in the spear Market you know you guys
are going from strength to strength the
card show obviously was amazing all the
care liberations what do you think that
e-commerce businesses can take from your
learnings within building this community
that are empowered to grow the brand
themselves you know vehicle has moved
Beyond you beyond just the characters
what do you think eCommerce businesses I
mean that brand
is the ultimate way to sell
right like brand over everything
the reason most people that Focus just
on math and ads don't build the biggest
things in the world is because the art
and the communication and the emotion
always outflanks the math you need the
math math is massively important
obsessed with ads we run billions at
vaynermedia but if you're asking me what
can an e-commerce business learn from be
friends and v-con the answer is brand
over everything
and brand means storytelling and good
intent and content with no expectation
of a transaction in return on that day
our last one oh team I've got to go the
next thing I'm so sorry go ahead um my
name is Patrick I'm a 17 year old
student I graduate high school at the
end of next year I come from a very
traditional like family who just made
really badly to become a doctor because
of its like stability and like respect
that you get given correct I feel like
that I've always been interested in like
entrepreneurship yes as someone with
your expertise and experience what are
your recommendations
yeah
and also um as an entrepreneur how do
people like you like gain the respect of
the like the general like population I
guess by execute
security right like I think it's so
common for Eastern European Asian Indian
parents for the doctor lawyer engineer
thing
the most important thing is that you
don't make the same mistake your parents
are making which is you're trying to be
respected
the best way to get respected is but not
by not seeking respect
it's by respecting others but not trying
to get it from them
right you're you're in a double path one
you're trying to figure out how the [__]
to not be a doctor because your parents
want it bad yeah and then second that's
fine that's a that's a generation that
is like a huge thing that's going on in
the world good news there are millions
and millions and millions of kids
predominantly from certain parts of the
world and immigrant families they're
being pushed to do the same thing you're
not alone on this but you cannot
compromise on this
because there's only one outcome you
will end up resenting your parents
if you if anyone here goes on to do
in a profession what their parents made
them do when they had no interest the
outcome is always resentment
the bigger thing that scares me is not
that it's looking for respect
that's going to put you in a shitty spot
for yourself
the only way to get respect is to earn
it you can't communicate it
but more importantly
try not to make that your validation
respect yourself
give respect to others you'll get
everything you need from that
Facebook I gotta go Brisbane
thank you so much
[Applause]
so much
[Music]
thank you